write a composition on the subtle
philosophy of the round and know the cow
cow is china's intends to de college
entrance exam students marks on the exam
are set to determine their entire future
life opportunities and earning potential
in China with a belief that those who
excel on the test will have the best
careers and even marriage prospects
college entrance is especially
competitive in China where the top
universities only select as few as one
and fifty thousand students
Wow that's pretty low that's like 0.002%
the test is so important that factories
and buildings will shut down while the
exam is under way as police cars patrol
to keep streets quiet ambulances are
placed outside exam facilities in case
of nervous collapses the multiple choice
questions are notoriously hard with
questions such as last October President
Xi Jinping said that while art is based
on imagination it should still be
down-to-earth there may be hundreds of
ways to create our best way however is
to trace back to the people's daily
lives and create something based off
that from a materialism point of view
this is because one art originates from
the daily lives of people two art
depends on innovation three the way art
reflects on society and its style is
unified for art is a form of ideology
that reflects people's lives while at
the same time serving the people this is
confusing I don't I have no idea it's
like kind of a logic question but it's
also a grammar question and it's also
related to current events and politics
just reading this gives me anxiety so I
can understand why people have
ambulances outside I don't know I'm
gonna say eight I'm gonna go be one in
4d
but literally it's saying the same thing
the Geico has been seen as symbolic of
the Chinese education system as a whole
and both the exam and the system itself
have been criticized for putting
impossible pressures on teens outbreaks
of suicides accompany every exam season
Wow
if your whole life depends on this exam
that's like so much pressure for one
person to handle especially if you're
still growing as an adult I mean if this
one test determines what happens in your
life that is really intense
the exam also includes a number of
essays with prompts that can be
notoriously obtuse such as do butterfly
wings have colors why is this an essay
question who do you admire the most a
biotechnology researcher a welding
engineer technician or a photographer
what the heck that's like a just a
personality question I'm suggesting
computing has been a rampant problem
including the use of spy cameras and
radio devices to transmit questions and
answers those who are caught cheating
may spend up to seven years in prison to
try to prevent students from pursuing
their increasingly creative methods of
cheating drones have been used as Hall
monitors whoa drones
people are cheating so much that they
have drones in charge this reminds me of
Minority Report like robots are
surveillance the containers for milk are
always square boxes containers for
mineral water are always round bottles
round wine bottles are usually placed in
square boxes right a composition on the
solo philosophy of the round and square
my god what these are so broad what do
you even say here I think Jays humanity
has gotten way too obsessed with tests
there are other ways to evaluate people
compared to what we have here in America
we're pretty pretty lucky it just seems
like if you're putting so much pressure
on a young kid about a standardized test
something's not right
I hope they relax their systems at some
point because I can't imagine even going
through that I'm just thinking more
about what is the sole philosophy of the
round and square